while 94 one man booth at calf lava
studio right now special guest he's
gonna be at the Orpheum tonight in Ybor
City sold out Orlando last night hey
post Malone what's going on
yo man Congrats on the success brother
this white Iverson is something else bro
you saw appreciation however how has the
new Fame like come to you like is it is
it kind of like a bit overwhelming yet
or it's wild you know it's a while but
you got to take it like a day at a time
and let it let it come to you because he
can't always just think about it all the
time you need downtime right no I mean
you need human time not just like post
alone time right right post me but so
it's kind of wild but you know like
adjusting to it you know it's definitely
a lot different than before yeah you you
you seem like you have a really positive
attitude towards everything which is
very important I try to yeah man your
your your you seem like a real happy
dude um talk about your uh your start in
the in the game because I saw that like
you had did a cover for like a was it a
Bob Dylan record or something
um and I always tell people like who
call you a rapper I'm like yo he you
know I guess you could call him a rapper
but it's just more like Iraq just makes
dope [ __ ] on our rapper right artist but
I can't right right right right right
right
um but how long have you been recording
music I've been recording music I don't
know I've been recording music for like
five years five years I've been playing
music for like seven eight so like and
then you decided to go to LA which was
like a big jump and I was 18 made that
jump and finally got like quality
recording make everything sound nice and
listenable right right is that where you
hooked up with fki yes a Stevie B studio
don't ya and they I mean you guys have
like a really dope sound man like thank
all the records are really fired I think
you man you know we're just working on
making something how many songs you have
in the can because I mean you don't have
a project out you're doing a lot of
shows off that SoundCloud cuz the
SoundCloud is fire but like when are we
gonna get a post mixtape EP something up
album hopefully by the end of this year
next year or finding a next year I'm
just figuring it out when we got a lot
of songs we got like 20 songs Oh see you
just sitting on them yeah we just want
to figure out and making
cohesive and fresh crispy crispy I can
dig it man
um a lot of people have been talking
about this Charlemagne interview that
happened which was a you know Charlene's
good friend of mine and he's got his
antics and I thought it was a very
unfair interview yeah I thought it you
know they were in attack mode from the
jump all right you handled yourself well
thank you um but but what what did you
come away with when you got out of that
interview were you like you know because
I mean you know they kind of just throw
you into the shark tank which is your
new and exactly ain't done this really
I'm 20 I haven't done no interviews like
this right whatever so you know it's a
lot different it's very different but
you know going into the interview we
didn't even talk about music yeah it was
like what what about the fact I was
white you're white what are you gonna do
the black lives matter exactly that's
not saying it's just like you know um
very extra but you know that's what he
does you know I can't expect anything
else I guess is it has it become like a
you another artist that has his girl
with him at all times is kidding is that
true yeah he's got like he's engaged
with a baby on the way he sounds like
I've known kidding for like five years
every time I've ever seen him his girl's
been with him far um yeah man it takes a
special kind of gentleman to have a
girlfriend on the road with you is it
been like like trying on your guys's
relationship with all the traveling and
although I'm sure there's some groupies
along the way no I don't pay no but it
takes a special type of lady to this is
really awesome would you call her your
unicorn plum princess my centaur Queen
your since our queen yeah that is great
babe but you know she's super super
super dope yeah very supportive and
there's been times where I was just like
I don't want to do this great music yeah
Jesus you know they're for me so super
now being from Dallas Dallas kind of has
art like has had spots in the music
industry where they've had a song pop
off like gyro at a record and lo will
had to dougie joint uh but that was
really doesn't have like an identity I
swear like Houston's you know obviously
everybody knows Houston but but um why
do you think there really hasn't been as
a
you're probably the biggest guy to ever
come out of Dallas as far as having a
following and and you know wide
Iverson's out of here but why why do you
think Dallas is kind of like still a
secret as far as the talent I don't know
I feel like now you know Dell is like
enterprising was playing me all these
boogie records and we was turning out
less I heard there's a crit crit
something was it like quit life yeah
they asked yeah they're cool year if our
gun is cool you know it's just people I
feel like there's not a medium anymore I
feel like it's really hard to get your
music heard out there you know
especially you know a lot of people make
music out there I'm just like anywhere
really so is I mean it's general
generally the same like but you know
it's tough because you can't really play
your music and there's not a lot of
studios and you know this is gonna be up
to that quality I feel like white
Iverson would be a song Drake would have
got on like you know Drake loves picking
out records yeah and hopping on them
have you like like as Drake acknowledged
you at all I gave you you have you had
any talk with his camp at all I just
feel like you guys would make dope ass
music together
no I think that would be cool too and I
seen him at UM Coachella and that's
where we linked and he knew me and he
was turning out we was turning it up it
was super cool but um we haven't made
any music it I won't work at 40 he forty
or four years a producer okay is that be
far he's dope but a Drake post-launch I
will be cool half and then you did this
Kylie Jenner birthday party he's very
lit yeah I bet it was her 18th birthday
man that's a big deal I think that was
like I think I saw you you might have
been on TMZ off that join us I know I
wasn't I was on TMZ another day you were
on TMZ though but uh how does that
happen I know she's been at like fan of
us like she's put to the song her
snapchat before and ride that stuff and
but but how did that did her people get
it to your people is she her people
emailed me and asked to book me on the
party and you know super cool cuz she's
actually like a real fan I stole I guess
you don't listen to just white opera
since she was like two young tears and
all that yeah here's what's that about I
good stuff and this that's super cool
you know I mean so she booked me and I'm
a James Harden and Chuck Liddell -
Iceman um James hard rocky was super fun
James Harden just came up on my last
thing yeah you guys like he was like
before like he was like you
kind of people work together I not as
James article as dope dude um the
concept for white Iverson uh how do you
like Helion what do you like 22 is any
twenty you're twenty Jesus you can't
even drink no I can't
this is it easy yeah we're gonna get you
some fireball illegally tonight yeah get
you turned up on that white trash juice
that's what we drink here isn't for real
fireball it's my kind of place
you like fireball yes I love fireball
I'm have a bottle for you at the show
tonight yeah is about to go down but yo
like you like like growing up like
Iverson probably was past his prime who
were some of your favorite ballplayers
by coming up that you watched Dirk Duff
obviously your formation Terry I mean
you're gonna just say Jason Terry Weis
and Jerry's awesome yeah he is he's he's
like one of the greatest role players of
all time I love Washington Sean camp
Sean camp was the man I love watching is
definitely just no I know what I'm
saying I J will white chocolate white
chocolate yeah that dude was a G so far
with the behind the back Lopez oh he was
the best Sophie was doing n ones like
mixtape stuff in regular games this
stupid is crazy so so cool
who else are you working with man like I
know that um you got your circle of
artists I know that you were on like a
Chevy Woods record but who else what
other collaborations can we expect from
postman coming up there's some secret
collaborations some secrets yeah we just
I mean just basically right now a lot a
lot of producers um you know Zaytoven
and quarterly digital Metro boomin
Charlie handsome
you know first oh I did uh songs with
Makonnen and Ferg ASAP ferg so those are
gonna be super very lit
very late yeah Makonnen and Ferg yes
very nice yeah now very far um the the
the big news that that popped off last
week and obviously we all grow up in
different situations but there was the
vine that came out that were you it said
the n-word in like a but I think you
were just like singing along so it was
like I mean it seemed kind of
insignificant no I mean it happened
right after the Charlemagne interview
exactly I think that's why and so I feel
like it was it was kind of like someone
was holding on to that
no but I mean what do you have to say
about that I mean you know there's
nothing really I kiss I you know 16
years old it was acting you know I can't
do nothing but take you back and you're
a kid yeah exactly man makes mistakes
100% all right well look uh the shows
tonight everybody makes you go see the
homey post Malone I hope the next
singles too young by the way that's like
one of my favorites just be that song
this crazy bro yeah white Iverson video
weird you guys should the white Iverson
video it was that Vegas desert this is
like look like okay outside of LA yeah
that that video is epic man did you I
like the fan made video that came out
that was very fire that was cool too
came up before yeah yeah it was kind of
cool though it's very cool yeah but
makes you go see him the tickets at $20
at the Orpheum tonight Ybor City
anything else you would like to say to
Tampa towards mom turn up yes
come see my dude tonight man let's get
this white Iverson on hey let's do it
man it's wild 94 won